Bonjour.
Lady Stark, quel bon vent vous amène ?
L’hiver est là, il m’est arrivé pas mal de merdes.
Certes, oui c'est peu de le dire....
Donc je voulais voir s'il allait m'arriver quelque chose de sympa.
Oh là ! C'est pas prévu ça !
Comment ça ?
Alors, je suis pas censé vous dire...
Mais je crains que pour vous... Que ça soit la même compote toute votre vie.
Je viens pour changer mon état civil.
Comment ça ?
Mon pote Sam m’a envoyé un corbeau, apparemment je suis pas un bâtard.
Ah.
Maintenant je suis Jon Targaryen, donc ça veut dire que je suis noble, je vais pouvoir officiellement me marier avec...
Avec ?
Daenerys... Euh... C'est...?
Votre tante.
C'est ma tante.
Putain ! Fait chier ! On peut pas se marier.
Bon moi c'est un peu particulier... Je suis amoureux d'une femme...
Catelyn Stark.
D'accord, donc tout le monde est au courant ?
Oui.
Ok... Euh... Donc, oui Catelyn, et je suis tellement
amoureux d'elle, je suis tellement obsédé par elle, que j'en suis attiré par sa soeur quoi.
Oh c'est... C'est pas grave ça !
Et sa fille...
Ah.
Annoncez moi n'importe quoi, par exemple que quelqu'un me dise "à tes souhaits" ou que je réussisse une omelette...
Ben c'est marrant ça, je lisais omelette là, mais non vous allez la rater. C'était une 3 champis, vous allez en mettre 4.
Vous êtes un Targaryen...
Oui...
Daenerys, c'est votre tata...
C'est la tata... Tata Daenerys, et elle est Targaryen...
Oui, puisque c'est ma tata.
Voilà, ça veut dire que vous pouvez...
Vous...
Pécho.
Voilà !
Ouais, en plus c'est même la tradition dans la famille.
C'est complètement le style.
Oui, je viens de croiser Jon Snow dans les couloirs là.
Mmh...
Apparemment, il aurait droit de choper sa tante ?
Oui.
Putain ! C'est...
Moi ça fait des années qu'on me pète les rouleaux sous prétexte qu’avec ma soeur on aime bien se faire des bisous dans les fesses de temps en temps
et lui, déjà à la base c’est un bâtard et maintenant, on apprend que c’est le neveu de la reine légitime et en plus, il a le droit de la pécho ?
Bah... C’est un Targaryen quoi...
En plus, le gars, il a le charisme d’une sacoche !
Je viens de croiser Jon Snow, c'est vrai qu'il va niquer sa tante ?
Ouais.
Ah ouais, parce que nous à la garde de nuit, c’est ceinture, pas de sexe.
La vie est injuste, mon petit bonhomme, qu’est-ce que vous voulez que je vous dise.
Et moi, je suis tout seul là comme un con.
Bien, bien seul.
Vous vous imaginez comment c’est chiant de se branl...
Ah là là là ! Pardon !
Je veux pas entendre. C'est pour...?
Pour se branler.
Ok !
Est-ce qu'on pourrait pas niquer ? Là c'est le moment je pense.
Non, c'est pas prévu, personne ne nique sur le mur.
Même une de nos tantes ?
C'est crade... Stop ! Merci. Vous pouvez sortir s'il vous plaît ?
Chaud, parce que là je bande, là déjà.
Ouais...
Daenerys de typhon de la Maison Targaryen, première du nom, Reine de Meereen...
Oui oui, c’est bon, pas la peine de fayoter.
Viserion, mon troisième dragon...
Qui est tombé aux mains des marcheurs blancs, oui.
Bah justement, parlons-en. Donc moi pour avoir mes dragons, j’ai fait une fausse couche, j’ai non-brûlé dans les flammes du bûcher de mon mari,
je me suis retrouvée à poil ! A poil !
Oui... Oui, j'étais pas là.
Dans des steppes au cul du monde. Et lui là, le Night King, il fait "boop" sur le nez de mon Visarion et c’est plié ?
Je comprends...
J'imagine que vous êtes là parce que vous avez tout gâché, que vous avez fait les pires choix et que même Jaime vous a laissée tomber ?
Je cherche la cave.
La cave ?
A vin !
Du picrate, de la gnole, du rouge, du blanc, de la picotte, de la tise, faites un effort...
Il y a pas ici, il y a que des vieux bouquins, de la poussière, des araignées, trois bouts de cailloux.
Ces derniers temps, plusieurs choses ont dû être réglées de manière assez rapide, il y a peut-être des petits morceaux qui ont été bâclés, voilà.
C'est de la merde.
De la merde, oui, non... Non, je dirais plutôt torché.
C'est la merde...
On est d'accord.
Bâclé.
Je veux dire, peut-être que vous avez une attirance, plus pour les rousses ?
Euh... Le frère de Catelyn par exemple, vous vous en foutez ?
C'est vrai qu'il a du charisme mais oui, je m'en fous.
Voilà, c'est...
On se sent rassuré quand on est à côté de lui, donc c’est pas rien quoi.
Ouais...
Ça donne envie de se rapprocher de lui physiquement quoi...
Vous êtes amoureux de lui.
Oui.
Pourquoi les filles ont pas le droit d’être des chevaliers ?
Euh... Je sais pas parce que chevalière c’est un genre de bague.
C’est pas un argument ça.
Non c’est un jeu de mots.
Et sinon ? Il y a une vraie raison ?
Mais la guerre, c’est un truc de mecs, c'est un truc viril quoi ! Les femmes sont de frêles créatures, c'est pour ça qu’il faut...
Woaaah, les idées moyenâgeuses ! Quoi !
Ben, je sais pas...
Jorah Mormont ?
Tout à fait, auriez-vous une minute à m'accorder s'il vous plaît ?
En fait, j'ai écrit une petite lettre d'amour et j'aimerais bien avoir votre avis.
Ben, je suis pas là pour ça, mais allez-y.
Chère Daenerys...
C'est mort.
Si, j'ai peut-être un truc sympa, à un moment il va y avoir un petit coup de vent et vous allez "Schla !"
Vous allez éternuer et il va y avoir de la morve, il va sortir de la morve.
C'est un bon gag.
Il y a plein de femmes qui voudraient pouvoir aller à la guerre
Ouais non, il y a vous, et peut-être l'autre grande blonde là, la grande tige.
C'est pas vrai, il y a plein de gens qui pensent comme moi, même des hommes.
Ouais, bon ben, quand tu auras pleins d'autres gens qui veulent la même chose que vous, j'y repenserai. Merci.
Ma bite !
Oui... Et ?
Ben, j'en ai plus...
Bon ben ça c'est du passé.
Moi aussi je veux que les filles puissent être chevalier.
Je ne suis pas dupe.
Moi aussi j'aimerais que les filles puissent être chevalier.
Moi aussi j'veux que les femmes puissent devenir chev...
Oh ! Putain la vache !
Ben c'est grillé, c'est ma tête là !
Bon Arya, Merde  ! On va pas passer la journée là-dessus, là je suis vané.
Vous voyez qui est Berta ?
Non.
La bossue avec une tâche de vin avec un pied bot, qui vend des poulardes.
Vous l'aimez pas elle ?
Elle a vendu des poulardes à Catelyn ?
Je crois une fois...
Je l'aime ! Je l'aime !
La souplesse, ça vous dit ? Non ?
Avec votre verge dedans ?
Oui.
Très bien.
En érection ?
J'imagine déjà pas votre verge dedans, ni la mienne d'ailleurs...
Vous voulez tester ?
C'est froid ou c'est ?
C'est froid.
Il y a une patologie, Catelyn Stark. Si je vous dis que c'est moi par exemple...
Ok... Stop !
Je veux juste me bourrer la gueule.
T'as pas du shit ?
Non.
Elle se fume ta plume là ?
Tout se fume quand on a vraiment envie...
Ben, vas-y envoie...
Et les loups ?
Je les aime tous.
Euh... bon, euh là admettons, ça c'est Daenerys...
Ouais.
Et là, avec tous ses petits copains, ta ta ta ta ta ! Tout le monde s'amuse.
Ouais, je vois très bien.
Ça c'est vous !
Ouais...
Vous, vous êtes là. A vie.
Ah !
Pour toujours.
C'est loin loin ? C'est quoi l'échelle ?
Ah ça, il faudrait une autre carte !
Ok...
J'ai vu...
Dans les plaines glacées du Nord, s’élever une sombre menace... Contre toute forme de vie...
De la corneille jusqu’à la rose dorée, du cerf majestueux à la truite vivace...
Tous vont se réunir, au son du flutiau céleste,
des volutes de fumée purpurine embaumeront les pupilles et les narines,
Dans une ultime célébration de la vie..
Ok ! C'est ça que je veux.